and now the nominees for Best live
action short film the confession Tinnell
Tim the crush Michael Kray God of love
Luke Matheny no way way Ivan Goldschmidt
wish 143 Ian Barnes and Samantha wait
and the Oscar goes to God of love
[Applause]
this is the first Academy Award
nomination for Luke Matheny
[Music]
got a haircut
hey everybody
thanks to the Academy for this amazing
honor I need to salute my fellow
nominees to now Michael Ian and Yvonne I
invite the world to check out these
films so you can find them on iTunes I
think you're gonna love them
also thanks to everyone at NYU's
Graduate film program first among them
Bobby Webster my my cinematographer gigi
DeMint Stefanie Walmsley Ryan Silbert
Steve deep Yanko my actors Marion Brock
Chris Hirsch Emily young also Levi of
Rhino
Rob Meyer Casey Smith Nick Ordway the
rest of the crew which I'll thank unlike
the thank you cam or something that they
do after that everyone at a paradigm wat
media finally my mother who did craft
services for the film
my dad the great state of Delaware and
last but not least my brilliant composer
in the love of my life
Sasha Gordon you're my dream come true
[Applause]
[Music]